كشف المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الايرانيه ناصر كنعاني عن التوسل الى
تفاهمات مع الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
من شانها حلحله ارضيه الاختلافات الفنيه
التي تعوق عوده الاتفاق النووي على حد
وصفه كنعاني اشار كذلك الى التزام ايران
بالتفاوض العوده الى الاتفاق النووي على
ان يلتزم بقيه الاطراف بما فيها امريكا
ببنود الاتفاقيه جاء ذلك قبل ساعات من
انعقاد اجتماع الوكاله الدوليه لطاقه
الذريه والذي اعرب بشانه متحدث الخارجيه
الايرانيه عن امله بان لا يشهد تسييسا او
ضغوطا على حد وصفه
ومن في انها تنضم الينا منفذه العربيه
راغده بهنام راغده مرحبا بك معي في هذه
النشره غدا راغده اولا يعني هل هناك من
معلومات مؤكده عما قالته الخارجيه
الايرانيه بانهم توصلت الى تفاهمات مع
وكاله الطاقه الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه من شانها
ان تحلل الملفات العالقه بين الوكاله وبين
ايران هل هناك من حديث وتاكيد على هذه
المعلومات
اهلا بك نايف يعني رفايا القروس يا امين
عمل وكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه كان في
زياره لطهران يعني بداها يوم الخميس
الماضي استمرت يومين عاد السبت ليلا وعقد
مؤتمرا صحافيا هنا في فيينا لدى وصوله
واعلن عن التوصل لاتفاق كان هناك ايضا
بيان مشترك صدر عن الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه والوكاله الايرانيه للطاقه الذريه
يتحدث عن يعني موافقه ايران على تزويد
الوكاله بمعلومات اضافيه والتعاون بشكل
ايجابي حول المواقع النوويه السريه الثلاث
الذين تحقق التي تحقق فيهم الوكاله منذ
سنوات وترفض ايران التعاون في يعني هذا
التحقيق ويعني هذا كان محل قرارين صدر عن
مجلس المحافظين خلال العام المنصرم لذلك
يعني هذا الكلام يصب في هذا الاطار ولكن
هناك الكثير من الخطوات التي اعلن عنها
غراسلي في المؤتمر الصحفي الذي عقده فور
وصوله الى فيينا ليل عادت ايران وكذبتها
ونقذتها وقالت بانه لم يتم التوصل يعني
هذه النقاط لذلك الان يعني هذا الجدل حول
ما تم التوصل اليه تحديدا ربما يعني يوضحه
جرس اليوم قبل ان يبدا مجلس المحافظين
اعماله سيعقد مؤتمرا صحافيا يعني بعد
قرابه الساعتين ربما من الان لانه جروستي
كان تحدث عن انه تم الاتفاق على اعاده
تركيب كاميرات المراقبه التي نزعتها ايران
العام الماضي من المواقع النوويه ولكن
ايران قالت بانه لن يتم تركيب كاميرات
جديده ايضا كروستي قال بانه او حسب ايضا
البيان المشترك بانه سيتم التعاون والوصول
الى المواقع النوويه السريه عادت الى
وقالت بانه لن يتم الوصول الى لن يتم
السماح للمفتشي للوكاله بالوصول الى هذه
المواقع لذلك ضغط كبير حول ما تم التوصل
اليه تحديدا في الجزء الثاني الذي تحدثت
عنه ايران بانه هذا يمهد للعوده للاتفاق
النووي هذا ليس محل نقاش هنا يعني اعمال
مجلس المحافظين تتركز حول تعاون ايران مع
الوكاله ويعني المفاوضات النوويه معرقله
لاسباب اخرى منها تعاون ايران العسكري مع
روسيا ومنها قام مع الاحتجاجات الدول
الغربيه تقول بانه الان ليس الوقت مناسبا
ابدا للعوده لهذه المفاوضات